the New York Stock Exchange will
temporarily close its famous trading
floor on Monday
switching to all electronic trading
after two people tested positive for the
coronavirus the Dow closed below 20,000
yesterday nearly erasing all its gains
since President Trump took office CBS
News business analyst Jill Schlesinger
joins us Jill good morning we've got a
trillion dollar stimulus package on the
table and the market still is incredibly
unsettled why well there are a number of
things that are playing into this
obviously just uncertainty about how
deep and long this period of economic
standstill will persist and I think from
the investor perspective while the deals
are on the table there is a sense
growing that a trillion dollars as big a
number as that is it may not be enough
we're hearing just but you know some of
the details coming out but really a lot
of the economists that I speak to
they're very worried that we're already
starting a recession that next quarter
that we could see a contraction in this
economy of ten to fifteen percent
guy's the worst contraction in the
quarter during the financial crisis was
down by about 8 percent so this would be
seismic over the next 90 days Jill I saw
an interview with a man this morning who
said when you hear you're losing your
job you just have to rethink your life
it was really very touching to hear how
upset he is and we all understand that
what's the potential for future job
losses well unfortunately economists
again they're really guessing so I'm
gonna throw numbers out there and
they're gonna sound horrible but we
don't know so I'm going to just frame it
that way there are some economists I
speak to who say they believe there will
be three million job losses just by this
summer that we could see the
unemployment rate spike probably mayor
be around six seven eight percent you
remember in the Great Recession we
topped out at 10 percent now on the good
news front a lot of those same
economists believe that as soon as the
virus levels peak and start to diminish
we'll see people come back to work and
that would be great news
all right Jill thank you very much